okay so I talked about my thoughts on
the initial comic con footage that got
put out about suicide squad new trailers
out so let's talk about that as often
seems to be the case with me and DC
trailers there's some good there's some
bad it's a bit of a mixed bag now let's
start with what's good I love the use of
bohemian rhapsody I like that song
anyway I like Queen and that song is all
over the place you can't pin it down and
I think that's a fun fit for this movie
and what this movie appears to be going
for with this group of really disparate
characters with his wide range of powers
who probably can't trust each other be
just being sent into chaos that it fits
it i think that works really good you
know what I think jared leto joke is
starting to grow on me I'm not going to
say that I'm completely on board yet but
I'm not as skeptical now there's
something about the just a manic energy
he's bringing and seeing shots that
appear to be from such varied points in
the film like we see him in a bunch of
different locations bunch of different
outfits and just seeing sort of the
consistent just crazed energy I'm liking
that vibe I'm still not completely sold
these things about the look I still
don't love but you know what I'm in a
better place with it after this trailer
that I had been up to this point I think
Hollywood may have finally found
something that Jai Courtney can do and
not screw up which is nice considering
they've been cramming him down our
throat for the past few years and it's
been terrible I sort of really like that
I would rather just be in a bar causing
trouble vibe that I get off of his
Captain Boomerang Killer Croc looks
really good in motion el Diablo looks
pretty good i like the little glimpses
of it looks like we're getting some
straight-up magic in this which is cool
because not only is enchantress got this
black or a thing all around her but
katana sword looks like it's you know
God some sort of glowy misty thing you
think the sword is actually gonna do the
soul-sucking thing that does in the
comics that'd be very cool i like the
vibe i like the feel the whole trail is
just very punchy which just feels good
and feels right that said there are a
number of things at particularly in
regards to harley quinn that are making
me nervous now it's not the casting it's
not even really the performance that i
got i have a feeling margot robbie is
probably gonna play this about as well
as it's gonna be played i'm nervous
about the way Harley's being written
though because the lines that she has
and she kind
gets highlighted certainly for longer
periods than almost anybody else and her
lines just they smack of trying too hard
if somebody really going what's the
kookiest thing i can think that could be
said and it just I it's such a fine
balance to write a character like that I
I think to a certain extent when you're
writing you have to dial it back and
just trust that the performers gonna
bring that level of kookiness and
nuttiness to it which is usually what
would happen in the animation her actual
lines were not really one liners are
particularly memorable in and of
themselves but it was the way that way
they were delivered and said that always
made them great it feels like here
they're trying they actually tried to
write lines that were crazy and kooky
but it just comes across as just trying
too hard I can't think of any other
phrase other than that you know I look
at the her voice and the voices in her
head line or the line she has after she
breaks the glass and takes the person
which is a cool action I think that
that's an action that really suits
Harley but then for line after that I'm
like is that mm-hmm and even though
where I'm seeing that is kind of
restricted to Harley in this trailer
itself it makes me nervous for the movie
as a whole because the trying too hard
thing was sort of one of my initial
criticisms when we first saw the first
images of the Joker it looked like they
were trying too hard to make him crazy
and I kind of dial back on that like I
said I I'm kind of digging what I see
about the junker here but now I'm
getting that same vibe off of Harley and
I'm starting to worry that the whole
movie isn't just going to be fun it's
just gonna be trying too hard to be
weird and quirky and I I don't know I
I'm hoping I'm wrong I really do because
there's enough energy and fun in this
trailer that it just makes me excited
way more excited than I am for Batman V
Superman certainly and a million times
more excited than I am about that first
footage of wonder woman that came out I
don't even think I have the energy to do
a video on that but in any case trailer
for The Suicide Squad have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about it please
go ahead like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at council of geeks check out
the council geeks podcasts on iTunes and
stitcher
and until next time this council is
adjourned